from 1994 to 2000 i lived in new york in
manhattan
i was there long enough where i started
to feel like it was one of my cities it
was home for me i left at the end of
2000 which means that now
i've seen apocalypses unfold
in new york twice on television i wasn't
there for september 11th and i wasn't
there for sandy but i feel them i feel
that i feel the losses of a city
um
well it's been long enough since the
hurricane passed that you can start to
see i'm glad to say
the beginnings of a return to
functionality in new york
the subways don't all work yet but you
can hear about the mta pumping out the
tunnels the power will come back on
things might still be worse than we
think in staten island new jersey
but
you can imagine
a return to the new york that
i
knew
there's a word for that concept it's
called resilience
and resilience is kind of meaning a lot
of things to urban thinkers now but in
this case it means the ability to
withstand a disaster right
and as we talk more about what to do in
new york you'll start to hear some
really interesting ideas um to keep the
city uh resilient like um raised subway
entrances to keep water from
infiltrating in another storm surge
let's say things like uh the the storm
gates on the thames outside london are
the ones they've been planning for a
long time in venice
you know these are all important ideas
they're i think half of what is a an
emerging
critical argument in urbanism the other
half is a
summed up roughly by another word
sustainability
so uh sustainability is um
making sure that uh you have things like
green rooftops let's say to keep water
from running off of roosters quickly or
bio swales or permeable
pavement to
let water infiltrate into the ground
instead of going into storm centers and
it's things like
bike lanes making a city's carbon
footprint less reducing a heat island
effect you know
cities are becoming more and more
important on earth the biggest cities
the ones with increasing populations are
also on coastlines coastlines are the
most vulnerable to disasters to rising
sea level and increasingly powerful
storms so we have to start thinking of
what we're going to do about cities in
the context of disasters
i'm oversimplifying this and i hope that
you'll write in and tell me if i get
these definitions wrong but the
resilientists are folks like i think
like the new urbanists who want to take
largely greenfield places without
buildings on them and build like human
scale downtowns and things that look a
little bit like suburbs and have places
that are
built to be
a little bit disaster proof and the
sustainableists are
folks like
i don't think they even know what
they're going to call themselves yet the
landscape urbanists or the landscape
ecologists or whatever the ones who are
interested in nature the kind of folks
who built the high line in new york
let's say who are interested in having
cities that are that incorporate nature
into them
and um
i'm probably oversimplifying this and i
don't mean to make the resilientists out
to be defeatists because
they're coming up with a lot of
important ideas too and you know the
super storms aren't going to go away
this is the new normal this is the way
the world looks now we need to figure
out how to defend our cities against it
but my worry is that as in matters of
war we tend to plan for the last
disaster
and i'd like to be a little more
sustainable about this i would like
instead for us to think about ways to
avoid the next one
you